OH, I CAN'T BELIEVE
I DON'T HAVE ANY FRIENDS.
NOBODY GETS ME.
both: ONE SHOT OF GOLDSCHLAGER.
- I THOUGHT I WAS THE ONLY ONE
WHO ENJOYED GOLDSCHLAGER.
- YOU KIDDING?
THIS IS THE FINEST
GOLD-FLECKED SCHNAPPS
THAT MONEY CAN BUY FOR
UNDER $12 A BOTTLE.
- ONE NIGHT, I DRANK
SO MUCH OF THIS STUFF,
I PANNED MY DIARRHEA
AND I MADE $80.
- THAT MIGHT BE THE MOST AWESOME
THING I'VE EVER HEARD.
- MAYOR TODD FORD.
THE CRACKHEAD MAYOR
OF HAZELHURST?
- AH, DON'T BELIEVE THE MEDIA.
THEY JUST GAVE ME THAT NICKNAME
BECAUSE I SMOKE CRACK
ALL THE TIME.
- WOODY JOHNSON.
- THE WHORE-PUNCHING HEAD RANGER
OF BRICKLEBERRY?
- AND THEY SAY YOU CAN'T GIVE
YOURSELF A NICKNAME.
BARKEEP, ANOTHER ROUND!
- MY FRIEND SAID HE WANTED
ANOTHER DRINK!
- OH, SHIT!
YOU BETTER CHILL OUT
BEFORE HE CALLS THE COPS!
- HA HA HA!
I'M MAYOR.
THE COPS WORK FOR ME.
DRINKS ARE ON THE HOUSE!
[laughter]
- TO THE START
OF A BEAUTIFUL FRIENDSHIP!